you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
I'm gonna give computer impossible
a couple more tries so let's let's see
if we could get a quiet position this is
one that I've played before just looking
to get my bishop outside the eventual
pawn chain and of course c4 okay
this Queen b3 stuff usually bugs me okay
and I think we're gonna have that soon
after takes Queen b3 alright I don't
know that there's really a more
convenient way to defend against a b7
than to bring my Queen to b6 it's an
ugly-looking pawn structure I do get a
file but this b5 Square will be weakened
I think I have to kind of go for it you
know as soon as he comes out here I'm
intending this of course and so my light
squares are more vulnerable over here on
the Queen section so the b5 square in
particular so if I'm to play knight c6
Knight b5 rook c8 I think we should be
doing alright let's just get him knocked
out there it's a half-open file alright
let's get here I am of course off of
this already open file so alright what's
coming soon is d3 bishop to have 4 but I
should be in time to and a sneak away
all right get my bishop here in castle
at least if the night lands here I won't
be getting hit with the fork where
should I miss my bishop go not so sure
you know this kind
turned out to be a dead piece with this
particular structure it's kind of
without active play if white keeps this
sitting so this is something I need to
maybe maybe I should try to get rid of
my bishop is what I'm getting at but
first things first I think develop my
bishop I wasn't sure okay if they're I
think I'm just gonna come back here no
that's not working that was foolish if I
go here just takes in the night here's a
fork so there was a difference and I'm
seeing
unfortunately I should have come here
right away not liking this position at
all all right let's try this
how to defend v6 I'm anticipating a
knight move here all right okay
my bishops hit my knight is here
yeah you know what's gonna happen soon
bad things for one but another I'm
seeing some night move to a 7 to
eventually challenge my rooks activity
on this file striking at this pivot
point let's take care for starters oh I
wasn't expecting that let's back up
alright so here comes the rock I have to
get castled of course so know what whoa
I've seen this idea before by the
computer typical computer chests ready
to sack on this square but more than
that it's getting ready to win this
night hmm really how could I defend that
this is very interesting hmm very
interesting a motif to be aware of out
of this pawn structure just the night
sitting on d4 and the bishop relocating
to h3 off of that main diagonal how
could I deal with that they don't know
Knight here I could defend but he's not
this isn't a reliable home could be
kicked with a B for
oh I think that's a this is like it
feels like it's already over
it feels like it's definitely already
over what a sad day ah man
really
it's that simple you could just make
this quiet moving put pressure on e6 I
don't know how to even deal with that
Wow I don't have a move here it really
doesn't feel like I have anything
this isn't helping me to take the rook
inviting a nun act in an act of peace to
the c1 square so how do I even improve
what do I do about this sac on e6
with my night it's still not working
there's eventual fork a mic king and
rook I think I'm just busted wow that
was quick
quick and painful um and if I have to
move my rook here I just I don't have a
move
this is not nice about I just I don't
have a move ah this is tough night see
five I guess I'll just go with 95 now I
have anything I just I don't have a move
I don't have a move I'm not saying this
is very surprising I mean I said I've
seen this before but apparently I was
forgetting that this was an idea let's
just make a move see what it does
I'm assuming v4 is gonna happen I don't
have anything there's nothing there
let's just see it carry through yeah
here comes a sac on e6 let's just resign
this one yeah this is game over right I
can't do anything could I go here give
up upon for what this night is just a
monster all right let's try one more
look let's see if we can get a decent
game that was ugly town let's try one
more over and done with okay regroup
here you could do better than that self
pep talk engaged here we go that's what
I like to see d4 d5 let's see something
quiet nice and quiet here something
where I could have a structure I'm happy
with it definitely wasn't happy with
double isolated what was it double
isolated be pawns that was no fun okay
new game copycat land so far if I push
here Bishop takes Knight Queen takes
bishop check Knight here followed by 94
no thank you
I don't want any of that let me just
double-check that c4 Bishop takes Knight
followed by Bishop b4 is very
inconvenient so let's not do that
let's go here Bishop takes
consider pond takes might not be a bad
option to just secure the e4 square
you
I'm gonna develop my queen though I
could always challenge a knight on this
square
so what about c4 now as soon as I do
that I'm striking at the center of
course but my queen is maybe tactically
vulnerable on the D file I am opposite
that Queen on d8 so candidate moves c4
Castle Knight d2 I'd really like to get
c4 Knight c3 and a more aggressive
square for my knight
let me just castle for right now you
know what if see five maybe I'll go here
okay see black is apparently okay with
doubled pawns as well securing e5 if I
take I don't want to take though maybe
it'll take me alright now I'm gonna get
this in c4 Knight c3 I'm fine with those
doubled pawns because they're not
isolated and there's a flight square
though it could be covered with the
Knight g4 one day but that shouldn't be
too much of a problem
sohow Queen b3 was my first instinct
another one is maybe Queenie - it seems
more aggressive keeping the Queen
opposite the king and still keeping an
eye on b7 this Knight maybe can't move
all right clean trade huh
it's usually good sign alright let's
let's let's see what you got in the end
game without the Queenie's let's see
what you have alright so we're the next
pawn breaks potentially e5 and c5
Brooksie one let's go for it
Brooksie 193 aha alright let's get a a
night out I want the nights off the
board computers too good with those
nights he could do better so where do
you think the next greatest square for
him is he 5d 3 tends to be a pretty good
home though he is on an unprotected
square he watches over about c5e 5
breaks considering just capturing now
let's capture let's see what black does
multiple ways to recapture okay rook c2
and then rook c1 yeah let's let's sneak
that one in King F 1 to e 2 small
improving type of moves here
all right let's get him working it's the
only half open file I have and now hmm
if I play Knight d2 takes takes my rook
is unprotected and then there's gonna be
some strike at d4 exploiting the pin so
it's not so easy to challenge the knight
is what I'm getting at huh okay well I
think at least for starters I could play
King f1 let's do that mm-hmm
b3 yep b3
it's nights within striking distance
maybe I'm close to challenging the night
now let's get my king here one more step
I'm still just a moment away from
getting hit with some crazy check oh boy
alright so this position is opening up I
don't know how great a fan I am of that
I've seen tactics here that are favoring
black and I like that with stuff taking
an a2 with 9c3 stuff
that's going to be a pain okay hmm all
right I don't have to take
yeah this is going to be a pain as a to
Pond and I don't I really am NOT a fan
of pushing it here
maybe I need to do that alright let's go
with a four I'm fearful open some take
on a two with Knight c3 and some lines
alright mm if I take with the pond I
don't think it's good to have an
isolated pond so let's go with that
yeah this is tricky definitely tricky
I'd like to play f3 but I'm dropping g3
that's not cool what about this B for a
5
my knight gets kicked I know I want to
be able to play back here to defend d2
so tough so tough this computer let's
see if I could secure my knight position
for just a moment less than 20 yeah
all right maybe it doesn't have anything
actually it's ready to take care huh
that's its big plan what about this
Knight here
oh that's painful I didn't miss that
ouch yeah I gotta come over here
this is it something painful is gonna
happen oh let's see can I get rid of
that Knight Oh at least I get rid that
night that's nice
five seconds get back over here defend
I'm crawling up into a ball it's my only
hope
all right let's get this pawn going the
pond slinky efore alright I need
Fenne still right here laterally and all
right I'm slowly making progress now
that the night is no longer around
that's nice I'm not sure where exactly
my king is going i am banking some time
that's nice I might get kicked back I'm
fine with that though I think all right
I got a defend I got a defend what is my
king think he's doing I really don't
know
all right now I'm in a pin here maybe I
could push a I want to trade off my a
pawn cuz I'm I'm just I'm seeing him as
a liability
I wanna keep both sets of rooks on I
could always run to g3 yeah he's not
gonna not gonna allow that so easily rip
d2 rook d2 would have uh maybe I should
go with g5 well I have I not played that
just yet there's a computer floundering
I'm floundering you know what's gonna
happen I'll lose on time I can't make
any progress come on I want to make
progress I really do you just have to
trust me on that
rook b1 oh it's not really doing much
shuffling every day g500 mating that
stuff I just got a move oh we're just
gonna go back and forth
maybe I should offer a draw what do you
got now it's it's officially declined
that yeah what kind of progress is gonna
make I need to start banking time is it
gonna do this see if I trade a pair of
rooks then this yeah there you go
well done well done man my King just has
to Duck and Cover
that's the big plan if
with if it's just one rook this king is
gonna have an easier time scooping up my
a pond this is wonderful technique right
here is this pond is eventually going to
be set into motion but maybe then I
could put pressure on them all right
let's see could I do this now with like
rook b2
hmm no seems like it could force a rip
trade if it really wanted to
I have no active pawn break this is sad
okay rook has to go back at least let me
get back over here I don't want to
allowed their ruck to get behind my a
pond so that's why I'm kind of keeping
my rook on the a file it doesn't have
anything I would really like to bang
some time but it's taken me about two
seconds to make each move so do I just
keep going back and forth with my king
well this pawn eventually move these
guys are frozen the F pond okay here we
go here we go here we go
now let's go no let's do this first
c4 yeah there he goes yeah I figured you
would do that yeah now that's gonna
start to be painful yeah look at that
King what a bug huh
what a bug that King is that pond is
gonna be scooped up oh we're gonna have
a rook trade really my king is still far
off uh uh yeah my king is a long long
way off this rook is very well placed to
to defend the base points even King and
pawn in game the rook at play here
King is a long way off I gotta try
something like g3 I hope that these guys
could do something I need to create some
active plan let's see it's not gonna
work out
yeah I can't even go here because of
rook a4 to be 4 this is what you call
gun
gun yeah let's just see play it out that
Kings gonna slide right over or that
that's dead that's a dead one time to
resign oh well at least a better sort of
better showing than that first one for
sure and a lot of shuffling in this one
I was fine out of the opening I thought
at least even after the Queen's are off
but that night I needed to get rid of
this tonight right here is one that I
would certainly like to go back to and
see how I could improve one of those
interesting moments I believe really
needed to address that Knight position
hmm yeah cuz again at this point right
here any any ideas I have of playing
Knight d2 to challenge this guy what's
happening I'm working myself into a pin
and then there's this 'if I've move
that's too tough to deal with I was that
night I really need to get rid of the
Knights I know that the computer
certainly messes up when they have just
a bishop in end in endings I've seen it
mess up but these Knights it's just too
good with the calculation skill and this
one right here I've just plain day for
not really move I want to play because
there's always that positional
concession that black could have with a5
at some point clamping down on this
structure that didn't happen in the game
but I was I was always fearful of what
sort of stuff this just go into the
analysis board real quick what was I
always fearful of right here if I didn't
play a 4 right here I was afraid of like
if I took recapture and now it's like
how do I challenge this like if I ever
come over let's say I do this so I don't
even know why so I can maybe move my
knight and push here without losing upon
like if I do this sort of stuff actually
let me just say if I challenge it right
now after takes instead of this let's
say a challenge try to challenge the
rook it's just running into trouble with
this sort of tactic takes Knight c3
I'm not trapping the knight or anything
of course I am getting this but I don't
know it's tough whenever that computer
has a knight but ok
those were the only two games that I was
gonna play and well I still hope that
you got something out of it even that
was pretty ugly okay take care bye
alright let's go let's see if there's a
tactic I don't think there is oh my
goodness there is it's really going for
this this is not correct though it's
definitely not correct